hi welcome to kids
uh
you made a mistake you shouldn't give me
this power
you shouldn't give me this power if your
intention was to disturb me you are so
mistaken
anyway welcome to kids you remember plug
and play put one prong
in yeah that game uh that was
effectively a nightmare
then you shake it all about this is that
game's kid brother
all right sorry this shouldn't be uh i
probably shouldn't find this as humorous
as i do
but i do oh
and then there was one did that game do
that intentionally or is that just me
okay whatever all right so this is kids
um if you don't remember plug and play
it had this oh and then i saw this game
and i'm like oh yeah this will be this
will be a trip
you know the game costs two bucks but i
think it really gets you on the therapy
over the long
time that you'll have to recover from it
so am i supposed to catch these
people i gotcha i gotcha oh
[Music]
hey
now this this
is what this
in the many years the games have been
perfected
who knew that in 2019 we would reach the
peak
of gaming prowess
all right see ya goodbye this
um oh well you're dead
i can only imagine hello oh hi
hey how you uh oh okay i thought you
were coming up to punch me as hard as he
could i would not have been surprised
hi hello hello oh
i knew it i
knew it i knew
it all right who's going to punch who
this time
this way up well
i don't know if that's the best way hey
kids
hey you crazy kid you get away from that
pit you hey come on now
oh well i tried to warn you
wait what this way i'm sorry
no that way no that way okay all right
well you both can be right
uh well if your friend jumped in a giant
hole in the ground would you do it too
yuppers peppers all right
oh
well i hate that am i supposed to do
something about the dangly penis
no all right
no i'm okay all right i'll see you
around hey it's been
fun but i'm gonna go now
oh boy um
all right
[Music]
i might actually vomit i don't know why
that's
oh i'm like having a physical reaction
to this
okay i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine
oh i'm still supposed to participate in
this activity huh
it's a group activity oh here we go
i'm uncomfy
are you uncomfy i'm uncomfy
get down there i don't like that i have
to force you down who goes speed demon
[Music]
there we go now that uh oh no wait no
that's a butthole
i know a butthole but i see one that's a
butthole
that very clearly has been leading up to
a butthole
that's a butthole no one can tell me
that's not a butthole
i don't like that the music's kicking up
here we go three two the only way
through a butthole
is reentry here we go
that's [ __ ] off
just don't let me die
hey you stuck what's wrong
hey come on now come on oh you can do it
oh
oh god it's the worst it's the worst
oh you crazy kids ah come on now how
about you yeah you get up there we go
goodbye yeah you best run away after
that experience
if you lived from that you would run
like i got here i gotta
all right and then get up hey oh
okay goodbye oh no
oh boy i hate it i hate it all right you
know what we'll play
to play two at this game two plays at
this game
two this game is two player two can play
hey wait don't
no don't don't do it don't don't
don't don't do it hey wait they're all
looking at me they're not looking at the
hole they're all looking at me i don't
like that
you get in that hole you get in that
hole
[Music]
that's too satisfying oh what this way
this way
no that way agreed no no it's not
working uh-huh okay which way
no no way that way no this way
okay you guys don't know [ __ ] do you
okay i just need to point you all in the
there we go
oh look you're
nice orderly line i like it
oh yeah you you saw what they were doing
you decided that was a good idea that's
that's wonderful thank you for this
experience that i'm
enjoying here oh oh am i am i a part of
this oh am i doing something here oh do
i have to
hey wait whoa don't uh what
i convinced two people
i'm a hero oh wait there we go
that's what i'm talking about just
divert the herd oh
is this like one of those things at
vidcon where there's a spicy new
influencer and
the crowd is just running to get a piece
of their hair oh
yeah you stupid go up not down you
stupid idiots
come on now all right all is as it
should be
hey where's costco huh you idiots
i'm making fool at you guys you're going
the wrong way
all of you are dumb and i'm smart
i'm sorry uh in the hole
it seems like i just made these guys go
around
[Music]
all right you distracted me by space
you knew the word that i liked and it's
space
this isn't space is it you tricked me
this is not
space this is the opposite of space
oh no it's the ocean i was stooped
i've been duped no not the ocean's
butthole
not davey jones butthole
there i go oh well
i hate it here we go again um
you know you know the developer like
found a way to do this mechanic
and was like ah yeah perfect
exactly what i was hoping for i
wanted this this is the best
you know oh no that's not right what's
going on here
all right some kind of siamese twin
digestive system or something
get down there just just go faster i've
already gotten used to this i don't like
that i've gotten used to
this but i've gotten used to this
all right well someone's constipated oh
god don't you hate these
la traffic jams it's just
the gosh darn worst get down there
uh uh here we here we go
get out get out get out get up
it i hate it ah i hate it
get up run no
i know where you are oh what the hell
what what are you gonna fight me huh
you're putting up your dukes
hey you can't put up your dukes to me
i'm
unducable you couldn't possibly be
duking me
don't even think about it
don't even suspect about it
all right
oh
i won't do it do it come on do it you do
it
no you do it no you no
you no you no you no no
no no no no you you no you no
yes you all right
oh okay all right maybe you shouldn't
have volunteered for this whoa you are
fast
am i supposed to stop you for any reason
or should i just let you korean off into
the abyss because i feel like
i want to do that and i don't want to
participate in this
as i've mentioned before i don't feel
like i should participate all right come
on
yeah let's go come on swim swim for it
come on you know you want to
go on swim swim to the butthole come on
come on uh we supposed to swim up
maybe oh i click and well
all right then if i didn't know i was
gonna be such a trendsetter maybe i
would have gone first sooner
oh you idiots you're all going the wrong
way i'm going the right way
you stupid fools don't you know
it is very satisfying i do like it like
the uh the elastic nature of the group
it's filling out pretty thick and heavy
that's good i get it and ah you idiots
this is the way out don't you know up
from down up
apparently
[Music]
oh that's pretty
[Applause]
okay that's pretty cool i like that
i like that now it's getting a little
cacophonous
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa
very nice okay or not
it's the world's worst applause like
this is a nightmare for me
at like a panel just like i say
something like we're gonna do great
stuff ah thank you it's just
so really really funny about it
i was hoping they would do it in the
order i did it i wanted to do the wave
oh hello
[Laughter]
oopsie poopsie did i do did i
doopsy whoopsie that all right
well this is head right in
i don't think there was any other way to
go there's some like super secret easter
egg in this game where it's like
man why does the developers like why
does everyone keep going for the
butthole
that's the bad ending what's a good
ending where's like a field of flowers
how come no one saw that
god these freaks these these freaks just
kept going straight for the butthole
i can't believe it all right well you
you can't trick me
ha ha stupid ha ha stupid
ha ha you're stupid oh yeah even steven
uh oh well not even
again bump
all right then that's that's
oh god yeah i would be scared if if
someone just fell out of the ceiling
out of a sky butthole that's pretty cool
okay that's pretty cool that's very
satisfying
there's something very satisfying about
that
that's pretty that's pretty satisfying
that's pretty cool i gotta admit
that's cool i like that that's pretty
cool
hey why are you chasing me hey don't
chase me
come on don't chase me come on what are
you oh i'm gonna get you okay i'm gonna
get you
all right you lucky i slowed down for a
second there
all right fine ah come on come on don't
you want to know where i came from
don't you want to know the way to the
hole it's the worst thing to yell as
you're running at people
don't you want to know the way to the
hole come on let me show you
it's a really cool hole you'll love it
behind oh okay goodbye whoa what a
weirdo
those idiots not going near my hole all
right anyway
or dead might be dead after everything
that happened i guess you might be
oh well hey come on let's go uh oh i
don't want to do that
go scooch over there tuck you in for bed
good night smooch get out of here
get out of here no no get out of here
all right fine
i didn't know i could do that
ah okay time for the epic slam dunk
shoo shoo shoo that felt good
and
[Music]
nope oh it's clappy time again cool
great
[Applause]
you guys are so coordinated i really
appreciate that okay
all right cool
the wave it's the wave
i was hoping for that you guys are weird
ah you freaks
[Applause]
these guys are a little weird
all right and back
like i'm all for surreal
[Laughter]
yeah that's right did it whoa all right
go
go go in squatch go go go
just you
know all of you
i do love the crowd mechanics i think
that's really interesting
it's a fascinating thing just a ton of
independently animated things
i mean there's probably a trick to it
but that's really cool
it's a cool concept like it's just
reaching into the depths of imagination
now everyone into the hole
everyone stop being all metaphorical
about and get in this hole
get in that hole get it
choir shut up get in the hole stop
singing
that won't stop you from getting in the
hole you get in that wall
it puts the lotion on the skin some halo
ass
[Music]
the thing aliens and they're like that's
the prophecy
it's come true the the the great beyond
the path the the light the we're all
gonna die it's beautiful
transcend whatever whatever the thing
was that they said
hurry up get in the hole really gonna
clog up your system
is this just one big allegory for
constipation or something like that you
know if you all pushed and shoved you
could get in there a lot sooner
just so you know i guess they are they
are pushing and shoving
oh that's weird
oh there they go oh now they're really
getting into it
oh yeah there they go oh yeah here we go
now this is what i've been talking about
my entire life oh yeah
circling the drain it's weird how when
things get on this scale they look
fluid it looks more like a liquid and
not necessarily just a bunch of
individuals which i guess maybe is the
point
all right that was great
i'm assuming that's the yep that was
great
i am gonna have a really weird dream
about this game
i know that but that was pretty cool
i think that was interesting that
definitely was
surreal and artistic i'm not one
for like a lot of modern art but
that's an experience and
i think we all learned something today
if you guys didn't learn the lesson that
is so
very painfully obvious in this game then
i'm sorry you your your iq just not as
big brain as some of the other people
here
i mean everyone if you know what this
game talk about
write and comment what moral was we all
know
it we all agree and if you faking we
so don't be pretend like you don't
understand moral
lesson behind kids here you do
dumb and we too smart to not know you
not
smart so there we go who made this
mario von rickenbach oh i have to scroll
through them
interesting interesting interesting
well done well done i did like that a
lot that was that was fascinating
very fascinating ooh you can replay your
favorite
nightmare visit it at any time yay
that was pretty cool i will admit that
was pretty cool so thank you everybody
so much for watching uh if you want to
play this for whatever reason it's in
the description below i mean heck
support indie developers like this it's
it's a cool experiment and it's a
surreal experience and it gets people
talking about
what the hell this meant so that's good
so if you want to see plug and play it's
in the description below if you want to
see other weird and surreal games i've
got them in the description as well
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you